- You guys should kiss.
- Just real quick.
- Yeah, you guys should kiss.
- No.
- We do it all the time.
- Awww, come on, it would be so cute.
- We've actually kissed multiple times.
- In this movie.
- Look, look.
(hip hop beat music)
- [Adam] Uh oh bud.
Yeah, I saw your selfie earlier man.
- Okay, cool, deal.
- [Anna] Oh I guess.
(laughter)
- Let's get a selfie with all four of us.
- Yeah, you need to take a selfie.
- That would be a good selfie.
- Selfie!
(hip hop music)
- He's winning the game you
guys, this is fucked up.
- F you, yeah right.
(laughter)
- [Adam] I don't know how to surf.
(hip hop music)
- All my moves are too
sexual for BuzzFeed.
All dicks out.
- I've just seen it happen too many times.
- And I say all dicks because
I do have multiple, so.
Multiple dicks out.
(hip hop music)
Yeah you probably do the
best impressions right?
- Can you?
I feel like I'm being
bullied into voting for him.
- Got a pretty good Adam.
- Let's see it.
- You do a good me.
- I don't know, it's
just making funny faces.
(laughter)
(hip hop music)
- I ghost everybody all the time.
I'm the queen of the French exit.
None of you will ever hear from me again.
- I did text you one time and then you
responded literally
like seven months later.
(laughter)
It was like, "What, holy shit!"
(hip hop music)
Oooh.
What do we got here?
- 100%.
100% the plan.
- What?
- No, never doing a wedding.
- Except if you marry me.
- It's legal now.
- No, but.
- I want everyone to watch.
- No, we're getting just eloped.
- Okay, well.
- If you're using both of us as examples.
- Okay fine.
- It makes sense.
- I want you guys to elope but also
it's a Lifetime Special.
- Whatever you want baby.
I just wanna live with you forever.
(hip hop music)
- You bitch.
Alright.
Well, you're trying to
get responses, you know?
You're trying to get matches so
what's the point of saying no?
(hip hop music)
- She did right?
Didn't you do that?
- Yeah.
- I mean no, she planned it.
- Wait, are you married?
- If your cousin's watching,
that was totally planned.
- No I mean, I was the
maid of honor and I.
- Planned your speech.
- Planned my speech.
And then I got really
drunk and then I wung it?
I wanged it.
- You wanged it.
- She wanged it.
- Then I wanged it.
So, that's fair.
(hip hop music)
- I don't think I've worn underwear
since I've been in Hawaii.
- [Aubry] Zefron.
- Let it breathe baby.
- [Zac] Strictly boardshorts.
(hip hop music)
I'm just gonna hold up all three of these.
- Oh yeah, these guys.
These guys.
- No, I'm sticking with my answer, yeah.
- Wait, um, I'd just like to acknowledge
that we went away and these guys changed
so I think you guys are
gonna need that in the edit.